détonation très fréquentes dans le ciel
de carquif
les civils ce matin
n'ont d'autre choix que de se terrer
dans les abris
les forces russes sont entrés dans la
deuxième ville du pays
violent combat dans les rues avec les
forces ukrainiennes
tire explosion filmé par des habitants
terrorisés
s'il vous plaît vous voyez cette vidéo
je suis dans la rue de Grasse dans notre
secours nous sommes des civils l'armée
ukrainienne communique sur la
destruction de cette colonne de blindée
russe
vive l'Ukraine dit ce soldat
pendant ce temps dans ce sous-sol dans
un hôtel du centre-ville les habitants
restent calmes malgré les froids ils
dorment ici depuis trois jours
nous partageons leur quotidien
les enfants insouciants jouent la
directrice de l'hôtel
c'est difficile pour tout le monde quand
vous voyez le danger s'approchait c'est
dur mais il faut se contrôler rester
calme ça aide
[Applaudissements]
ces fillettes nous chantent spontanément
l'hymne national
ukrainien
comme un défi lancé aux Russes leur père
est très ému
bien sûr j'ai peur c'est normal c'est la
guerre
mais quoi qu'il fasse les Russes ne
feront jamais de nous leurs esclaves
la journée sera longue dans ce sous-sol